My new batch of Chinese herbs caused my intestines to feel raw and caused diarrhea.
To this person is taking Chinese herbs from a different practitioner.
Because I was so depleted, I didn't IV right in the sea with methylated bees
with a glutathiral push. Now I feel this was a mistake.
I have flu symptoms, low fever and spasm in my neck. Any suggestions on how to feel better.
So let's talk a little bit about the methylated bees that you would get in an IV.
So really all so typically if you're going to get to be vitamins in an IV, they're going to be synthetic.
They're not going to be whole food vitamins.
So I'm not in favor of getting taking the vitamins in an IV at all.
Unless the person's got is so damaged, they can't absorb bees and you have to do it that way.
Then you have to do it that way.
Doing methylated bees on one instance, like an IV of methylated bees isn't going to be a mistake.
So that in itself, just because they were methylated, doing it one time, don't consider that a mistake.
I just don't want you taking methylated bees on a supplement on a daily basis
when your whole system is within normal limits because you can be causing those other things that we talked about earlier.
I have flu symptoms, low fever and spasm in my neck.
I don't very much it was from that one instance of methylated bees.
And I doubt that it's from the glutathione, though I know the person asking this question is very sensitive to different supplements.
And when you're doing IVs of any supplements, you're taking fairly high doses so you're really flushing your system.
So the fact that that took place could be an issue.
So a lot of people will ask, can I do glutathione with my IV vitamin C?
Because the practitioner that equate to that's doing IV vitamin C.
She said we could do these other things in the IV too.
Of course, they're selling bags of this stuff, right?
Well, is a bag of glutathione beneficial?
Well, the answer is yes and no.
So when you're using glutathione, so go back to the seven phases of detoxification thought process detoxification is like a river.
So if there's a blockage anywhere or let's say not just not a blockage, but there's an impingement somewhere in through that river.
And you start pouring more water into that river up back upstream, then you're going to cause a flooding downstream.
And that's where that's what maybe is what you're experiencing.
Glutathione functions really on the phase zero level because glutathione, yes, it does support phase two pathways in the liver.
Because glutathione does function there, but glutathione's primary function is really intracellular.
In all your cells, it helps.
It's so important that way it is your main intracellular antioxidant.
But it also will if you have a lot of toxins in cells, it can dump toxins if you have take excess glutathione, it can dump toxins into the blood.
It can overwhelm if you if your phase one pathway is a little restricted, you could have excess toxins flowing through your bloodstream, trying to get out through phase one of the liver and phase one of the liver is like, hey, dude, we have a waiting list.
You have to keep circulating at least toxins that the circulate again coming back to the liver again.
Hey, can I get in now? No, no, I told you to take a number and they have to circulate again.
That's what makes you sick. So when you use key laders in excess, when you shouldn't be using too many key laders, I see this often where people are like, I did a test with my practitioner, it said, I had mercury toxicity.
He put me an EDTA and DMS, oh, and this DMSA and this key later to pull out this mercury because I got to get this out of my body and I felt sick after it.
It's because of this reason why I'm saying so.
The only thing you do is support the liver, support these pathways, make sure that you're having good moments, do coffee animals if you possibly can.
If you can't make sure you do a castor oil packs over your liver, make sure you're doing hot packs at least over your liver, make sure you're using binders to grab onto stuff so that that's not the pinch in that you're reabsorbing this stuff.
And drink a lot of water just kind of flush yourself up and you should be fine.
But I got a still sensitive, you know, that is dealing with this new batch of Chinese herbs that's caused your intestines to me an issue.
I've said that's why I don't use Chinese herbs because you just trust the suppliers and there's too many contaminated stuff coming out of China to be honest.
So using some things just to call me your stomach is going to be your best thing call me your gut stone.